s'il fallait risque alors que ce soit en
normandie ou dans l'est de la france que
nous venons d'évoquer ce sont les lignes
électriques qui ont été très souvent
arrachées ou abattus plus de 120 pilotes
sont endommagés deux millions de
personnes auraient souffert des coupures
d'électricité des agents edf font ce
qu'ils peuvent mais évidemment la
demande est très grande et très
impatiente commentaire d un margaux sur
le dispositif de secours et plusieurs
conséquences de la tempête sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
les géants de fer ont été terrassés par
le vent 120 pylônes plus de 5000 poteaux
électriques n'ont pu résister à la
tempête
débordé edf a dû réquisitionner
plusieurs milliers d'agents pour réparer
ces lignes et mettre en place une
cellule de crise comme toutes les
équipes techniques sont mobilisés il est
extrêmement difficile de répartir à très
court terme des moyens entre les centres
qui sont moins touchés vers les centres
qui sont très touchés
ce soir neuf cent mille personnes sont
toujours privées d'électricité l'est et
la région la plus touchée suivie du nord
est de l'île de france
enfin dans le sud ouest frappé ce soir
par la seconde vague de la tempête
cinquante mille personnes sont déjà dans
le noir la situation est dramatique pour
certains agriculteurs comme ici dans la
marne sans électricité pas de
refroidissement le lait est perdu
on retrouve des groupes électrogènes
tenir comme ça en temps vous avez
journée ça sera pas dur à faire pour les
autres il faut s'habituer bon gré mal
gré à vivre dans l'obscurité
mais je voyais plus d'éclairage
bientôt il faudra plusieurs jours avant
que le courant ne soit rétabli partout
en france les pompiers s'affairent pour
réparer toiture et cheminées mais pour
certains bâtiments il est déjà trop tard
le moulin de valmy symbole de la
victoire révolutionnaire ne se relèvera
pas de cette tempête là